what's up guys
bang bang it is friday lunch money time
but while she's trying to get rich
the rest of us just trying to get our
lunch money right wall street is
acting a fool that's all right
i'm here beautiful intelligent please
just put my finger on the chair
no uh just so we're all clear for all of
you men out there all you husbands
uh and boyfriends you guys know how it
goes i didn't have anything to do with
it she smashed her finger and i got
yelled at
that's what happened that's exactly what
happened that's how we're going to start
off this youtube video no problem
don't forget that block fight is now a
sponsor
go to blockbuy.com go get a blackfy
account
they are the best i'm an investor i sit
on the board i'm super happy user and
you
will be too go to blockfy.com
pomp 8.6 apy in an interest bearing
account what's that the sec said friday
it will work to protect
investors by reviewing the recent
trading volatility that has fueled a
meteoric
rise in stocks like amc entertainment
and gamestop
in a statement the sec vowed to protect
individual traders
and to scrutinize actions taken by
brokerages
that may disadvantage investors or
otherwise unduly inhibit their ability
to trade certain securities
is is the sec standing up for like the
retailers
the game has changed all i'm gonna say
is
whatever you want to look into just make
sure you look into them
and then is the establishment look into
the brokers
look into the hedge funds look into the
banks
look into all of them right i don't know
what happened
i don't know what's true and what's not
true but if you're gonna do an
investigation
don't be just trying to go on reddit and
find the reddit post and compare them to
the trades
you better be looking at what phone
calls were they making what emails were
they doing
who was doing some funny business in the
legacy world too
i'm sure that when there's volatility
like this and crazy stuff going on
there's a lot of talking a lot of
chatter out there and so
just make sure you look at everything
that's all chatter yeah by the way just
by open the market and let people roll
the robin hood it looks like they might
have almost gone out of business
yesterday if they didn't stop so we'll
see what happens
this is big citron research andrew
left's firm
which was forced to close out its short
position in gamestop amid a frenzy in
retail buying
said friday it will no longer publish
short reports and instead will focus on
long
positions after 20 years of publishing
citron
after 20 years of publishing there needs
to be a comma here citron will no longer
publish
short reports the firm said in a tweet
we will focus on giving alongside
multibagger opportunities for individual
investors this is huge
reddit they pulled out the memes they
pulled out
their virtual swords and they took down
one of the the biggest i mean isn't that
one of the biggest short songs
that's like me playing golf okay
it's literally me they just took down
the short sellers
if you're a short seller you're a loser
all right that's my opinion if you're a
short seller you're a loser you know why
because you spent your whole day trying
to be a pessimist and come join us
alongside why don't we talk about how
there needs to be a little bit of
pessimism
to keepers should check okay by the way
i can think
that it's good for the market to have
short sellers but i can still think
you're a loser
like come be an optimist come join me
and all the optimists as we look to
build the future
why you want to always be out there
yelling and screaming about
they're a fraud this isn't going to work
because it's not fun to be a pessimist
but sometimes they are a fraud and
they're doing something
yeah nefarious and they are there to be
a check i'm all about it listen i
fully understand i think that we should
have short sellers i think that they're
healthy for the market i think they make
a more efficient work i actually think
that they help
regulators as well right in terms of
they find some of the fraud they have a
financial incentive to do it all that's
fine
so that's like my rational view but then
when i just put on my internet hat i'm
like yo
stop being a loser and come chill with
us
come do the memes come play on the
internet come be an optimist
looks like citron research is now doing
just that andrew left you're the man now
you were a loser but now you're the man
if you're a short seller and you want to
be the man or the woman
stop being a loser short seller and come
join us over here
in all series i'm i'm playing around a
little bit but in all seriousness the
market does need short sellers to make a
more efficient market
but come on how do you spend your day
all day being a pessimistic got your
point
you've made your point stop being a
loser it's friday let's come on
come come join the internet
what coinbase
coinbase plans to go public via
direct listing the company announced in
a blog post today
the cryptocurrency exchange uh blah blah
blah
yeah it has filed for its s1
confidentially with the sec
and they're gonna do direct listing
right yeah uh let's go
so why do you think coinbase is doing a
direct listing he doesn't want to deal
with the roadshow and the bankers yeah
they uh a whole bunch of reasons but
yeah i think they probably just think
it's a better way to go public that's
fine and brian armstrong
who i think is very intelligent has
talked publicly about it in the past
that uh he thinks the ipo process is
broken
so i'm generally a big fan cool
obviously i'm an investor
all right come on come on they also
disabled trading today
but it's because there was such a surge
in demand that
uh them cracking a bunch of people they
just they can't handle it and i know
people get pissed off
they should be pissed off uh but it's
just it's impossible to understand how
much
of a surge of interest if you if you
have technical challenges
that's different if you say hey across
our entire product we're gonna
we have to pause for a second to fix the
technical stuff
what happened yesterday with robinhood
that's not what they did what robinhood
did was they said we're gonna pick
individual
stocks that's not good april is tax
season we're about to enter it
god that came quick huh um but
it may come with a big surprise changes
to federal
taxes enacted under the tax cuts and
jobs act
means that many people who didn't update
their w-24 form
likely had less tax withheld from each
paycheck in 2020
many who lost work due to covet and went
on unemployment will owe
tax on their benefits as well so please
do your research before tax season so
you don't have a big
surprise you know who else is losers is
the tax people
like imagine spending your whole day
just being like i gotta go find that 27
that they didn't pay me in taxes like
come on
come join the optimist on the internet
come
include yourself in the meme warfare i'm
having a blast this might be the most
fun i've had on the internet in a while
if you're a short seller or you're a tax
man come on
come get a great job go to pomp
cryptojobs.com you can come join the
revolution
and let's go do you remember i think
it's world war
one when this happened or maybe world
war ii i can't remember but like
two countries i think was like england
and fans or something and
uh it was it was christmas day or
christmas yeah christmas day
and they like put their weapons down and
they like played soccer together for one
day and then they went back to fighting
it's kind of like that
you want them to join you on the
internet side for a day and then go back
to
doing you know i want them to join us
forever no okay
all right next okay okay so um
today i saw that today
remember that um don't don't do it do
not do it
today is international puzzle
day which is awesome it's celebrated
today was created in 1995 by game
companies in the united states
but do you want to know oh my god do you
want to know a fun fact about puzzles
why it's called the jigsaw puzzle okay
well i'll tell you anyway
it was believed that in 1767 mr
john spillberry an english cartographer
cartographer means he made x maps
made the very first jigsaw puzzle when
he mounted a map on a sheet of hardwood
and cut it using a saw he challenged the
public to reassemble it and then became
a popular
educational tool and that is why today
we have
jigsaw puzzles that's my favorite you
love puzzles i know i do love a good
puzzle i haven't done one in a while
because
it always takes me a while and then he's
like why is this on the dining room
table and i'm like because
it's taken a while it's a thousand piece
puzzle
you know who else is a loser people
people who don't like puzzles
ah i knew i'd get her to agree with me i
don't like puzzles so whenever it makes
me a loser i'll join
you guys on the loser side for a little
bit everybody can't be a winner 100
of the time you know what i'm saying we
got a ask lunch money time
for those of you who are new i saw we
got a lot of new people yesterday use
ask lm in the comments so that i can see
your question i can ask it
real time live okay um brent kt
uh pomp what are the most important
things
to consider before deciding to invest
other people's money
ps it's my birthday this saturday would
love if you guys can encourage
everyone to support small business this
weekend keep up the great work
long bitcoin short the manipulators yeah
that's short
happy birthday brent happy birthday to
you happy birthday to you happy birthday
to brent happy birthday to you to
support him
on his birthday go support a small
business this weekend
um okay answer his question what are the
most important things to consider before
deciding to invest
other people's money make sure that
you're investing your own money well
it's pretty much that easy if you can't
invest your own money you should invest
other people's money if you can invest
your
money really well then you should invest
other people's money uh as long as
you're willing to take that risk and you
got to understand what goes into that
because it's not just
the ability to raise the money it's not
just the ability to invest the money
it's also to
clearly communicate uh to provide uh
reports
to do it in a legal structured way all
that stuff also isn't it true that like
you shouldn't invest other people's
money
in companies that you are not yourself
willing to personally invest in
yep of course okay good all right guys
you're so good
go to readtheprofile.com and go check
out pluma's newsletter see you
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block fight
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends